Nikomako Nekomata, I wonder if this is cattle feed.
It sure looks like it
February 8th
Webber
Now this is it
Yes 4 I want to stop If I don't stop it I'll just have a head and tail like that picture
Akki's cow ever
This t-shirt is good
That's a pencil cap
Medusa Did you
really look like me?
I see, I actually knew it too ban I was
watching
ban
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh hey
he's the roots of my race
But we're a race that's lived in units of years The
roots are me
Ah, my
wife Rufa's youkai left only the necessary things.